A chartered airplane carrying a Brazilian professional soccer team...
...has crashed in Colombia.
Officials say the plane was on its way to the airport in Medellin.
It's believed it went down in a mountainous area outside the city...
...just before midnight Monday night.
Eighty-one people were reported to be on board the British Aerospace 146 short-haul plane,...
...including members of the first division Chapecoense team from Southern Brazil.
There are reports of at least six survivors.
The team was set to play in the South American Cup finals...
...with the first of two games set for Wednesday.
Aviation authorities say before the aircraft went down,...
...its pilots declared an emergency due to an electrical failure.
Sandy Kozel, The Associated Press.